go Blue did Disney just learn a lesson
about the phrase go woke and go broke
the House of Mouse putting out a
financial statement which seems to
acknowledge that its controversial
political and social agendas cting the
company and shareholders the document
says we Face risk relating to
misalignment with public and and
consumer taste and preferences for
entertainment travel and consumer
products but Disney isn't the only
company that's facing a woke Reckoning
check out this headline for maxios the
Dei backlash is here the article talks
about how companies are slowing down to
diversity equity and inclusion efforts
since the Supreme Court's affirmative
action ruling in June uh judge the legal
uh put aside the ruling for one second
you sense this from your conversations
with people and how do you think in
addition to that the legal ruling may
impact how companies behave going
forward well first of all I am so glad
that that Disney is is suffering the way
it's suffering in March of 2021 they
were selling at
$21.9 a share they're down to 95 that
was a self-imposed injury all right they
jumped on the the woke bandwagon and
they thought that they were going to
make a fortune they didn't do it for the
right reasons they thought that the
country's going woke and this is
something that we have to do but you
know when a little girl walks into a
Disney Store they just forget who they
are and sees the Fairy Godmother with a
mustache I that's going to mess her up
for a few days um but but the whole idea
that Disney thought that what China and
Russia that they were gonna buy into
this stuff it's not going to happen and
the downward spiral is welld deserved by
them that's all I have to say man I I've
said on the show I don't know what woke
is or toxic or what should be cancell
you been that's all we talk about I know
but what how do you define woke like I I
mean what what is woke I don't know I I
was I was just going to say this is the
market at work right this is the market
at work and now Disney is saying okay
whoops it's sort of like Bud Light they
do the trans thing like oh shoot we got
to pull back or shoot how about oh yeah
probably um or Major League Baseball
right they pull out of Georgia Atlanta
for the game and now they're going back
yeah and guess what the law that made
them leave in the first place that they
were so upset about it's still on the
books so I think a lot of this is just a
resetting for everyone I would also like
to say that South Park one of my
favorite shows nailed again a few weeks
ago they had this fake Disney board
meeting and for every idea that came up
there was one guy who said I know put a
chick in it and make it really lame and
it was just very funny and
prant uh come to you I'm come to you
feel you feel validated here as you hear
some of the some of the fact that this
pullback is happening and that it's
really the market that's doing it as
opposed to politicians well I'm not a
fan of Disney World I've had bad
experiences I got food p Wasing at is it
Epcot and then uh I had really bad seats
at a parade when I was little and so
Emma's actually taking both children
Jesse Jr and Gigi to Orlando this
January I'm not going W not because I
don't want to go is because I need to be
here I need to be working she going to
send her there alone she's going on a
flight with two children I think she's
crazy but she wants to go so I'm going
to let her go but other people other
people care they're principled consumers
like when they saw that video that I
aired at 8:00 of Tinkerbell at the Ural
at Disney World people said I'm never
going back to that place again me I go
back I see songs and I'm and I don't
care if that person hates Fox I'll turn
it up or I'll go to a restaurant that
dairo owns if the food's delicious I
don't care most Americans are more
principled than I am and and they will
see things at Disney and they'll say
I'll never go into Disney World well I
go to chick-fil
suay Greg finish us out here how do you
how how do you reckon with this I will
Define woke for you it's when if you see
everything through the lens of power
whether it's relationships recreation
entertainment if you see everything
through the lens of oppressor versus
oppressed then you will never actually
enjoy yourself that is why people who
are woke are no fun that is why
Disneyland sto being fun because it
wasn't about its core principle its
mission statement which is making people
smile the moment Miss universe is about
gender politics it's no longer about its
core Mission which is beauty if you look
at Victoria's Secret if you looked at
Bud Light anyway you can't have two
bosses right and uh especially when one
of the bosses has no metrics for success
and that is what Dei is the you have two
tracks of success now two competing
tracks one is for the shareholders and
the customers that's the one that
matters the other one is for consultants
and race Hustlers and the media one will
grow a company the other one divide it
the funny thing is the people that are
involved in Dei which are are based on
dis centering whiteness in the workplace
and the Sy the symptom of whiteness
would be profit seeking and
competitiveness but in their own orbits
they use those exact same rules when
climbing the ladder when they're arguing
and negotiating speaker fees do you
think they stop thinking about how could
I make a profit they're a bunch of
Hypocrites and they should all be fired
you can only have one boss and it's me
I've got three they're at home at my
house coming up we've got a big holiday
secret to share with you find out what
it is next hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else